le déconfinement annoncé pour le 11 mai
comment on se prépare l'ile-de-france à
la relance de son activité alexandra du
blanc chez lui evelyne oise à
sartrouville élu à la région vice
présidente en charge de l'économie et de
l'attractivité était avec nous bonjour
bonjour avant de rentrer dans le détail
des mesures d'accompagnement aux
entreprises qui ont été mises en place
peut être un sentiment plus globale avez
vous des inquiétudes sur la reprise du
duo 11 mais on sent bien que le
déconfinement ne sera encore que très
partielle à nous notre enjeu à la région
ile de france c'est évidemment le goulot
d'étranglement que représentent les
transports on essaie de mettre en place
avec valérie pécresse toutes les
conditions pour que cela se passe du
mieux possible cela commence nous avons
demandé dès le départ le port
obligatoire du masque ça veut dire
évidemment équipé les usagers on a déjà
distribué 1,6 million de masques ces
deux dernières semaines dans plus de 220
gares d'île de france
on a également demandé à l'état cinq
mille personnes forces de sécurité en
renfort pour nous aider à réguler
l'antre des dégâts par ailleurs nous
avons signé hier avec les organisations
patronales syndicales les organisations
de transport la région et l'état une
charte pour encourager les entreprises à
maintenir le télétravail pour ceux qui
le peuvent a également aussi utiliser le
lissage des heures de pointe
c'est à dire au lieu d'arriver à 9
heures j'arrive entre 6h30 et 7h30 et je
repars entre 15h30 et 16h30 par exemple
avec une attestation a signé par
l'employeur
et donc voilà puis on va mettre des
distributeurs de masse de gel dans les
gares donc c'est ce qu'on essaye de
mettre en place pour lundi mais
l'activité est fait défection
économiques et liées au transport donc
voilà pour les mesures qui ont été ont
été prises jusqu'aujourd'hui la région a
lancé plusieurs raids pour les
entreprises dans le cadre de son plan
d'urgence si on peut déjà évoqué le fait
le prêtre bon par exemple c'est avec mes
bpi france un prêt à taux zéro tout à
fait ce prêt a été lancé mardi
c'est un prêt donc effectivement à taux
zéro entre 10000 et 300000 euros pour
les entreprises jusqu'à 250 salariés
il y à un différé de remboursement de 2
ans et ensuite on a sept ans pour
rembourser rembourser ce prêt avec des
pays on va mettre environ 150 millions
d'euros sur ce dispositif
il n'y a pas de caution non plus
personnelle du dirigeant le but c'est de
pallier les manques de trésorerie les
besoins de trésorerie des entreprises
les besoins d'augmentation de bfr besoin
en fonds de roulement tout ce qui est
investi matériel et immatériel et
matériels et on veut être le plus
réactif possible donc ce prêt s'il est
un fer à 50000 euros
il y aura une décision dans les trois à
cinq jours et au delà on s'engage à
donner une réponse dans les sept jours
il ya un fond de solidarité aussi je
fais un peu le point sur les différentes
mesures un fonds de solidarité jusqu'à
5000 euros pour les plus petites
entreprises devant à dix salariés
exactement ce fonds de solidarité c'est
un fonds national dans lequel la région
ile-de-france mais 150 millions d'euros
c'est pour les effectivement moins de 10
salariés et ayants à moins d'un million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et qui ont
connu une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
d'au moins 50% par rapport à l'année
dernière donc il ya eu un volet 1 qui
pouvait aller jusqu'à 1500 euros et un
volet de il faut en parler puisque la
jolie de france ne fait pas encore assez
appelle les entrepreneurs les
commerçants et or c'est un fonds
national volet 2 qui peut effectivement
aller jusqu'à 5000 euros pour ceux qui
ont bénéficié de la première la première
vague mais dans le même esprit elle est
de toutes petites entreprises du btp au
café aux commerçants associations aussi
d'ici la fin du mois de mai c'est une
avance remboursable
baptisé résilience oui alors je me mets
à la place un des entrepreneurs qui nous
écoutent
on n'essaie pas de multiplier dispositif
on essaye de parler de vraiment de
répondre aux trous dans la raquette des
dispositifs existants le prêt rebond il
répond peut-être à voilà au manque du
pge du du prêt garanti et un se font
résilience c'est pour aider les plus
petits effectivement entre 0 et 20
salariés on le fait tous les territoires
d'île de france c'est à dire chaque
territoire par exemple dans les yvelines
pour a
bonifié se font mettre un bonus pour
pouvoir aider les entreprises du
territoire donc donc voila et donc c'est
vrai on est en train de monter ce fonds
de 100 millions d'euros avec tous les
territoires d'île de france les
départements on l'espère la métropole du
grand paris pour arriver à un fonds pour
aider les plus petits les commerçants
nos commerçants nos artisans nos tpe
pour les aider à rebondir une c'est la
question que j'allais vous posez
justement il ya une multitude d'offres
dead qui sont mises en place
actuellement l idée pour la région c'est
de maillet au mieux de ne laisser
personne de côté et de répondre aussi
bien aux besoins les plus grosses
structures que des plus petites aussi
exactement nous fait vraiment la cible
c'est surtout les plus petits mais bon
vous voyez que le pré rond va jusqu'à
250 salariés donc ça prend bien les pme
mais vraiment oui effectivement il faut
aider tout le monde a passé cette crise
et nous on essaie de rattraper ceux qui
peuvent échapper peut-être à certains
dispositifs actuels à nationaux et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on crée d'autres
dispositifs ça peut faire peur un peu
comme ça mais on essaie d'expliquer de
communiquer d'ailleurs je vous en
remercie pour que nos entrepreneurs
notamment yvelinois 1 s'en saisissent ça
du mieux possible et un numéro de
téléphone qui va s'afficher 01 53 85 53
85 ses lumières au téléphone qui a été
mis en place par la région pour
justement les entrepreneurs mais pas
uniquement toutes les autres personnes
qui pour avoir des questions sur ce qui
a été mis en place par la région depuis
le début de cette crise début du
confinement notamment depuis le 17 mars
si on peut faire un point aussi
peut-être plus générale sur l'impact de
cette crise sanitaire sur les
entreprises franciliennes aujourd'hui
pour la plupart des entreprises cette
crise sans précédent elles pourront s'en
remettre écoutez on fait tout pour
et elles le font aussi alors il ya des
secteurs qui sont particulièrement
impactés je pense évidemment au tourisme
la restauration qui ne va pas reprendre
lundi
donc c'est aussi pour ces entreprises
qu'on met en place ces dispositifs sont
au tourisme on réfléchit beaucoup aux
vacances de cet été
peut-être
doté les franciliens de chèques vacances
a dépensé en ile-de-france pour aussi
contribué à la reprise du touriste tout
ce qui est vainement ciel aussi c'est en
une situation très compliquée donc nous
on essaie d'être couteau suisse pour
faire face à ces situations et que
personne tout le monde puisse survivre
un maximum de d'entreprise et donc on
pense aussi voilà les conclusions qu'on
tire de cette crise sur la
relocalisation notamment on en parle
beaucoup il ya des maillons manquants de
chaînes de production qui a été très
visible pendant cette crise je pense à
l'industrie du médicament par exemple
mais dans tant d'autres filières et donc
nous on est déjà en discussion à peu
près depuis un mois avec ces filières
pour voir comment réorganiser nos
productions dans les yvelines je pense
ceci évidemment à l'agriculture dont je
les ai également la charge
on a vu un regain de local dans vie de
local de nos concitoyens et nous on veut
que ça perdure on a annoncé d'ailleurs
hier des mesures pour l'agriculture par
exemple sur le l'aide au financement
vous savez on a eu beaucoup drive
fermiers de la vente à la ferme donc
nous on financera région jusqu'à 70%
toutes ces structures pour qu'elle
perdure les agriculteurs on a envie
veulent se retrouver ce contact
on essaie de le faire depuis des mois
mais la crise a amplifié le phénomène
est donc ça il ya parfois quelques
points positifs de cette crise et donc
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on veut
essayer de pousser mais envoyait une
question qui subsiste en derrière tout
ça il ya beaucoup d'autres qui sont
mises en place
ça veut dire derrière nécessairement les
impôts je te faut bien financer tout ça
réponde à ça vous savez quelques
résidentes pécresse on a une gestion
extrêmement rigoureuse des des fonds de
la région depuis notre arrivée on avait
fait un milliard d'euros d'économies
donc on est toujours très attentif à la
façon dont on dépense voilà on suit ses
dépenses pour l'instant tout ce que je
vous cite une et 156 millions d'euros de
fonds de solidarité les 150 millions
dupré rebond s'est pris sur le budget
actuel n'y a pas eu
on entend beaucoup parler d' ouverture
des vannes au niveau national et à nous
c'est pas du tout le cas trois sondes à
les revendre à des règles très strictes
pour les collectivités donc pour
l'instant on essaie de redéployer des
crédits pour mais il ya un moment où il
faudra faire des choix et j'espère quand
même que l'état va nous aider à pouvoir
être et c'est le cas pour les communes
aussi ça je suis à sartrouville je suis
élu à sartrouville nous aider parce que
pour l'instant les communes prennent à
leur compte toutes ces dépenses d'achat
de masques notamment aussi donc on
attend vraiment une aide de l'état là
dessus une toute dernière question
puisque vous l'avez rappelé vous êtes
est lui aussi dans les yvelines à
sartrouville la réouverture des écoles
dans votre commune se passera comme en
écouter un nous notre mère a voulu rang
alors ils appliquent strictement le
protocole fournis par l'état et ensuite
il laisse la possibilité aux parents il
est trés dans une approche plutôt souple
de cette reprise de l'école et je pense
que c'est la bonne approche
il faut pas forcer les parents il ya
beaucoup d'angoissé donc chacun fait
comme il le peut comme il le veut c'est
important quand même de reprendre les
écoles pour reprendre l'activité
économique
c'est important mais il faut le faire de
façon la plus agile possible en étant à
l'écouté des besoins aussi des
enseignants qui sont très anxieux des
parents et puis pour le bien-être de nos
enfants
merci beaucoup alexandra dublanche vice
présidente à la région ile de france en
charge notamment du développement
économique
merci merci